bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get in this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got roll
here thank you so much for doing this
sir
you got it man good to see you bro
absolutely let's just jump right into it
uh this will be a fascinating
conversation
uh you spent a long time as a police
officer there's all kinds of things
between the company that you're building
today
and also a lot of police reform stuff
that we're going to cover but uh just
give us kind of your background and
how did you eventually become a cop yeah
man so um
look i i've i spent the last 10 years or
so in public safety overall
on the public safety side i started as
an emt uh paramedic you know i went to
university of pittsburgh worked out
there as crew
chief uh you know on the fire rescue
side a little bit and then mostly on the
ems side uh as a paramedic there
um and then you know had a couple things
i'm sure we'll get into it uh
things that happened in my life that
made me decide maybe i want to try being
a police officer
uh and i came back to la where i was
born and raised i became a cop out here
in
in 2013 um left full-time i'm a reserve
officer now which is
essentially uh it's the same thing as
you know full-time police officer except
get paid way less and and you don't have
to worry about the scheduling you just
kind of put in what you can
uh and started uh spider tech um in
2015. so that was uh
the public safety side on the tech side
you know i've been in since i was a kid
man i was
had my built my first little video game
at 14 and then had a little start-up in
digital currency before bitcoin was the
thing
uh back when i was in high school uh you
know doing like
game currency and stuff like that and
that paid my way through college a
little bit and
uh worked on apps and public safety
after that and eventually merged my love
for tech and public safety with spider
tech
awesome i uh i'd love to see it so let's
start a little bit with kind of
uh the story now you've got this kind of
pretty uh crazy story around racial
profiling and
and uh before you became a police
officer that really kind of drove a lot
of the way that you see the world today
so we just gotta tell that story and
then what were some of the takeaways
from it
yeah so um for those of you that are
listening and not looking
uh i am a browner man and so it's a
little bit
that's a little different uh for me in
that sense
and uh you know i grew up um in la you
know dealing with racism here and there
especially after 9 11 and
and you know things were toned down but
when i was working as a uh
as a paramedic in pittsburgh
pennsylvania um there's one incident
that occurred that
that uh you know made the news um i was
again on duty
uh as a crew chief of the uh of the rig
basically
heading to a 911 call up north where my
area was uh driving ambulance and
uniform et cetera
had my emt with me as well she was also
in uniform uh we were driving
up the i think it was 47 i'm trying to
remember the uh the exact highway but
um there was a there's a vehicle like a
white suv
that wasn't a police car was unmarked at
least and it was driving up the shoulder
to try and
it got like really looked like it was
angry at us and it drove up the shoulder
of the highway to
take a look into the cab and see who was
driving which was me at the time
then it pulled up behind me um and then
all of a sudden i saw it turned on its
red and blue lights
and so i pulled over again in the
ambulance on the side of the highway
thinking okay
i don't know what this is all about uh
the guy that popped out uh
you know kind of short stocky white
older dude who
uh wasn't wearing uniform no gun no
badge kind of walks up to the car
and flashes an id that says police but i
can't read it because it's too fast and
says
pittsburgh police and he starts cursing
at me what the [ __ ] are you doing and
are you even a real [ __ ] paramedic
and all kinds of stuff and i'm like yeah
i'm this is a
driving ambulance uh i'm you know this
is not an elaborate ruse
um so he asked me did you feel the uh
didn't steal the ambulance there did you
yeah well that's actually
so just wait for this part of the story
because it can crack you up the uh
the guy you know i gave him my paramedic
id because he almost doesn't believe me
so he goes back and checks to see if i'm
a paramedic
he takes my driver's license check to
see if i have any warrants again i'm on
duty as a paramedic driving to a call
um and he comes back and kind of throws
at me he's like i'm coming at you with a
for a warrant you cut me off in traffic
some type of road ragey type you know
complaint
um now i'm 22 i think at the time so i'm
you know like this is ten nine ten years
ago i'm nervous i'm going oh [ __ ] i did
something wrong
so i get on the radio and i tell the
chief hey look i just got pulled over i
think i'm in trouble
uh and he tells me hey come back to the
station so uh the district chief at the
time
and he finds out the guy calls the
district chief to complain about me
this trip's like dude he's an ambulance
he's he's being an ambulance right now
what are you talking about um so you
know i get there and the district chief
says hey i just did some digging
i found out the guy that pulled you over
is the chief of police
for pittsburgh school police and
the guy has no jurisdiction at least in
the state of pennsylvania uh to be
pulling me over on the highway and on
his personal car would you know like
it's an absurd thing to do
so he calls uh the city and complained
and i find out like a couple weeks later
that was the last draw for that guy they
fired they terminated him right off the
bat
uh i guess he's had plenty of like road
rage incidents and the guy just wasn't
cut for the job
now a couple months ago he's suing the
city to try and get his job back
i have to testify my district chief has
to testify uh
my partner emt at the time has to
testify so we you know i go to court
i swear to god bomb this guy i'm i'm
sitting in court this guy
says when they asked him why they pulled
me over i mean i'm i'm
this is word for word he says he thought
i was driving a taliban war wagon
that's that's the terminology used and
he and i'm the only one who's laughing
by the way like i don't think anyone
else had the courage to laugh at this
absurd moment in court
um because i'm just like i can't believe
this guy said this then he explains
that the fbi taught him how to racially
profile uh and then like the quotes in
the news uh
articles if you if you google it you
know he was saying that um
he the fbi told him that that terrorists
are driving around the country
uh in uh cloned ambulances that could be
car bombs and so he was trying to
protect the city of pittsburgh
for me basically uh maybe blowing
something up and um
it was crazy man it was absolutely crazy
after that i remember like
civil rights groups etc they're kind of
approached me hey this is a
slam dunk lawsuit with the city that
wasn't what i wanted to do i'm not
trying to take money away from the
school board
or the city or you know my legacy is i'm
you know
it's just not what i want to do but it
made me feel
terrible man it sucked and it taught me
at the time like i had a i didn't have a
good you know
perspective or at least i didn't feel
good about cops that was one of a couple
things that had happened
right just had this kind of narrow
opinion on cops and
i had all these opinions on how they
should be doing their job and i remember
um one of my uh one of my district
chiefs actually
told me hey do you maybe you want to try
being cop
in instead of firefighters some other
things are paramedic there's some other
things that had happened
and uh so i decided [ __ ] it i'll put my
money where my mouth is and i came to la
and i became a cop and i immediately
found out
like 90 of the things that i thought
were you know how it should happen etc
was
wasn't true i was wrong about the vast
majority but the idea that there are bad
cops out there there's racism
you know out there within the world of
policing um
that's still true that yeah like that's
something that i did find to be true
whether it's more far and few in between
or whether it's you know more targeted
specific areas it's a whole different
thing
but it was an interesting experience for
me so i gotta ask
uh as somebody who's in the military
i've never heard the uh
terminology taliban war wagon
[Laughter]
what exactly is that great question dude
i still don't know but i can tell you
it's not a [ __ ] ambulance
you know this is an absurd phrase
yeah no it was it was pretty creative
and i don't know where he came up with
it but like it's got the alliteration at
the end it rolls off the tongue
um it's a good buzzword uh he tried to
be a little bit more proper and call it
a cloned vehicle the disguise just an
ambulance
um but uh it was already too late you
know the vernacular stuck in my head
yeah that is absurd all right so uh you
go what were the most surprising things
when you became a cop
uh that you were just like whoa that's
not what i was expecting uh
or i actually thought it was like 180
degree difference than the way things
are done
yeah good question man look i think that
i i did already know about the reality
of violence you know like that
that is a concept that a vast majority
of people especially in the united
states do not know they just don't
understand it they have a tremendous
amount of privilege they don't know what
it feels like
to be stuck in a violent circumstance
where
you it's it's essentially things end up
turning somewhat primal and you have to
either defend yourself or defend
somebody else
and you have to make decisions that you
never thought you'd have to make like
that that aspect of the job i understood
enough having
encountered a lot of the you know the
the essentially outcomes of that
violence as a paramedic
um and i also understood that the field
is a very dynamic
you know situation it's you can't train
for every possible circumstance
uh you can't you certainly have to just
trust the people you've got you have to
be able to install some discretion
put policies in place but there's never
gonna be a perfect scenario there's
never gonna be perfect legislation or
policy around that that much i knew
and of course you you spent time in the
army right so
those two things i'm sure are also
things that you've learned what i didn't
quite
understand um i guess not having been in
this situation at the time was
what it's like to be responsible
for like if you're in a scenario where
you know you pull up on a traffic stop
and it's just a regular traffic stop why
cops are thinking
like why they do the little things they
do why they might approach the car with
their gun out
why they might stay behind the second
window um you know why they might
why it's so important to see somebody's
hands um how quickly
this is something i learned how quickly
you can go from somebody's hands that
you can see them
do you getting shot in the face i mean
that's like one one and a half seconds
the reaction time's there until you
train for those circumstances it's
pretty crazy um
i didn't quite understand uh at the time
how the use of force continuum worked
you know that like i'll give you a more
recent example like the idea of a cop
choking somebody to me was like that's
crazy
until i started doing jiu jitsu and
learning um you know
policing and understanding the
difference between a cop choking
somebody in the carotid restraint
you know things like that just didn't i
didn't know
i also didn't understand how the law
applies to things
and and um you know the difference in
reactivity and proactivity in terms of
like
going out there and stopping folks
versus you know we're showing up to a
901 call and how that changes the
circumstances there's plenty of it
i could dive into but i just a lot that
i didn't understand and
the laws behind what's the difference
between murder and manslaughter everyone
just used the word murder
and everyone thinks everybody should go
to jail and how that process works is uh
is different too yeah it uh i always
tell a story of uh to people where uh
you know i was in the military go to
iraq i come back
pretty comfortable with weapons uh other
people carrying weapons you know
generally that doesn't freak me out in
and feel uh
like i you know can do what i need to do
if i've put in a situation
where it's necessary but uh when i came
back i was probably back
six months 12 months whatever it was and
i was driving
in a pickup truck that i had
and it had tinted windows but it was
dark out as well
so you know kind of hard to see into
into the vehicle and i was driving on a
highway and i had my
younger brother at the time with me i
think that he was probably
14 or 15 years old and they see the
passenger seat i'm in the driver's seat
and so uh uh as i'm driving on the
highway get
[ __ ] pulse behind me turns on the sirens
uh i pull over to the side of the
road and you know again it's dark out so
you basically see the sirens you can see
the headlights
you can't really see kind of you know
who's approaching or whatever and so i
rolled down the
driver's side window uh and you know in
generally well
uh enough educated to you know put my
hands on the steering wheel like don't
make any sudden movements you know shut
the car off like all the like super
super basic stuff that
uh you know most people shouldn't know
uh at this point and uh all of a sudden
it just pounding on the back passenger
window
and so i'm like what the hell right so
all of a sudden i start to roll down the
passenger side driver window and the
cops got his flashlight
out his gun drawn and he's screaming at
us
and what i realized very quickly is that
he screamed at my brother because my
brother doesn't have his hands up you
know on the dash or whatever
yeah and so uh very quickly you know
yell at him to get his hands up i'll
show y'all at the cop like yo my little
brother's in here
like chill the [ __ ] out right and uh
it's one of those situations where
you know the cop is you know he
eventually he puts the gun down and
explains hey look you know sorry about
kind of startling you guys
but uh recently there had been a
shooting pulled over somebody on the
street
uh they turned around they shot at the
cops something that actually hit the cop
but
all the cops were just on edge in
general because that was kind of a
reminder like be extra careful
uh and so being at night with tinted
windows whatever like it you know it
makes sense in hindsight
but sure as hell didn't make sense we've
got his gun drawn his you know
flashlight basically in our eyes and
he's yelling and screaming and so
it's one of those situations where uh
you forget that like basically two
strangers are meeting on the side of the
road
uh neither one of them has contacts
about the other person what they're
thinking
uh what they've been through that day
are they tired or they're not tired like
there's so much complexity that goes
into it
and if that happens millions of times
a year tens of millions hundreds of
millions of times a year of course
things are to go wrong
right like like statistically yeah it's
just you you can't stop them all and so
what i think ends up happening and
what i want to talk about next is kind
of like the police training it seems
like the police training if done
correctly just drastically reduces the
probability that things go wrong it
won't completely eliminate it
but it at least takes it from hey maybe
there's a three percent likelihood to
can we get it to you know
tenth of a point of likelihood that
something bad's gonna happen
yeah it's it's you know it's a good
point man because you know when when we
talk about what can be
improved with police training i think we
have to talk about like how they're
trained today
right um yeah i went through a sheriff's
academy
uh in in california that's known as one
of like the more
intense you know stress academies that
still exist today
um and you know it was it was fantastic
training look the thing the thing about
being a cop is
it's a dangerous job i mean i like
people float statistics about how other
jobs are generally more dangerous but
you're more likely to get killed by
somebody you know like literally
murdered in this job
and the thing about training is that you
what
from a safety standpoint what they try
to train cops
is to know what to look for and to trust
their intuition
and to not take chances um and in the
case that you're describing to me you
know i don't know what the the rest of
the context is you know
but uh you know pulling up behind the
rear passenger door
what they call this the c pillar there
uh ensures that like they have an
advantage over you if you're gonna try
and
you know pull a gun keep approach from
the passenger side instead of the
driver's side
which is another tactic to try and
surprise people in case there's some
they're
laying weight in the ambush and it's at
night you know if it's a night you know
they're pointing lights at your
your rear view mirror and your your uh
your side mirrors so that you can't see
them approach and they're avoiding
silhouettes
so they're doing all this and it might
sound like over the top but
there are so many cops that get shot on
standard routine
traffic stops where you have to go
through the process
of basically treating everything a
certain way and then
in your head like understanding it in
your head that this is the way it works
but creating body language for the other
people that essentially de-escalates
them and makes them feel comfortable
so if i walk up to a car i don't know
who it is like the way that it works and
i'm sure you felt like this in the
military you have to kind of think okay
i don't this person might be the nicest
person in the world i'm gonna act like
i'm the nicest person in the world in my
head i'm gonna have a plan to
eliminate them as a threat at every
moment every second i'm sitting thinking
where are their hands going
um and this is just the nature of the
job now the training isn't
we should remove that from the job
because that is that is a necessary
element
the the the nature of violence nature
field you have to be
um you have to be cautious you have to
be thinking about these things
there are ways to i believe improve
these outcomes
not just based off of the training that
like in these individual situations
but the types of situations that were
you know officers are constantly putting
themselves in
in the first place right um one thing
that i think is kind of interesting is
the defund movement as they've talked
about it um you know i agree with some
of it
i don't agree with with all of it one of
the things i agree with is the idea that
the police are being asked to be the
solution for problems that they
shouldn't be asked to be a solution for
homelessness addiction mental health
you know these are things that require
other specialties
that have been kind of thrusted upon the
police over the last several decades
that shouldn't be thrusted upon the
police and because of it they're now
putting themselves in a lot of
situations in which
sometimes these dangerous outcomes exist
now the difference between
what is being proposed potentially by
some activists and
the practical uh you know version of
that you know some activists feel like
you don't send the cops to these calls
you don't send the cops to like let's
say
a standard mental health checkup call
for example and i'll give you an example
this just
video was just released like two days
ago uh
and it was just a regular routine
welfare check
um in ohio and i'm still trying to
understand the details of all the you
know everything but
as i understand it it was just a call
for a person who might be potentially
suicidal
um did i don't think he threatened
anybody necessarily but he was suicidal
the officers walked up to the front door
one officer kind of and she was smart
she
kind of canted herself from the door so
she's not standing right in front of the
door
she put herself in a position to advance
something you're trained to do no matter
what
and the guy she's like oh hey the guy's
coming to the front door just get ready
to have a conversation
the guy opens the door pulls out a gun
this all happens in about half second
tries to shoot her in the head
she is you know she's got training she
rapidly drops
to her like you know crouching position
to avoid the rounds
takes out her handgun starts exchanging
on fire if i was
if she's not there or if there's no
officer there's a routine medic
a mental health call uh whoever showed
up there would have gotten shot
the guy didn't even look the guy just
kind of opened the door and pointed the
gun at whoever that was was the nearest
person
i personally responded to calls and you
see this happen all the time where you
respond let's see to a bus
and uh someone's kind of making someone
uncomfortable because they keep talking
to themselves and that's it
benign mental health call and by the
time you show up that person stabbed
three people
with a screwdriver and you go okay it's
all evolving by the time you get there
so
the idea of replacing cops versus
supplementing them with mental health
resources that are
actually in charge of the scene unless
it turns violent unless it turns
criminal
makes perfect sense but you can't remove
the fight
the funding for the cops themselves
because they still have to respond so
there's a lot it feels like also like
there's an argument between like
hey don't send a police officer send
like let's say a mental health expert
right okay
that's one kind of extreme of it the
other extreme is
uh send the police as they are today
right right and
i think that the in between in there is
actually what happens if we send
police officers who have mental health
expert training
or if we send a police officer plus
somebody who has mental health training
right like like
there's not there doesn't have to be
such a black and white world like
there's actually some
nuance and uh kind of centrist view here
of how can we provide the best care
for citizens without also putting them
in danger or putting
other people in danger right to your
point about the guy who walks through
the front door and just starts shooting
like yes we don't want to put the
persons at the home in danger
but we sure as hell don't want to put a
mental health expert in danger either
right
yeah and i think that compromise
honestly that practical compromise is
is key uh you know there's
this all takes money here's the here's
the issue it feels like defunding the
police
came out as a kind of a punitive
strategy that kind of backed into
a more logical approach but
uh the uh the concept of just taking a
money away from the police department
doesn't solve anything
because i i'll tell you this we were
touching on training earlier
there is a lot of training we could be
putting officers through whether it's
mental health
whether it's uh you know advanced
tactics in in terms of de-escalation
whether it's more understanding of the
law and how it applies for fourth
amendment purposes
i mean there's so much more you could do
people are constantly complaining
that um the cops don't get enough
training for example i mean that's
something that
i think even cops would agree with to a
certain extent um and it's also state by
state so that's different but
if the average cop is getting paid less
than 50 000 a year
and they're not being trained enough and
you're also complaining which is
a valid reason you could say that hey
the quality of cops that we're hiring
aren't high enough you don't solve that
problem by reducing
the resources even more and reducing the
funding for the training and for the
better cops
and all the things that we want to do
similarly the the compromise that you're
describing
where the cops are better trained you
know uh for for on
mental health how to handle those
scenarios and we're also sending
mental health professionals or homeless
liaisons or addiction specialists to
these calls with the cops
even saying that cops are secondary and
those specialists are primary
and they only get involved if they have
to and they can even stay out of
out of view i mean you can do all of
those things it just takes more money
but if you're stuck on the idea that the
cops need to be defunded
and you're explaining it backwards then
the no solution gets found i mean it
doesn't solve anything
so when we talk about police reform in
general what are the things that you
think
makes sense like what are the practical
solutions versus the things that are
just absolutely asinine and completely
impractical
yeah well i mean i think the first one
we've already touched on a bit which is
uh alternate resources and social
response
i think that's one of the best things to
come out of the last several months
in terms of conversations around police
reform i think it's something that
that police departments have have long
since embraced the idea of
and have implemented for years i know
seattle pd one of the industries that we
work with
uh experimented not only with um
actually having mental health responders
respond in the field several years ago
but also by ensuring that those mental
health responders were actually putting
valuable mental health data for for
people who are constantly in contact
with the police
what i mean by that is like what are
their triggers what are their hooks like
what are the things that they
what calms them down what are their
de-escalatory techniques what are things
that upset them
and they put that information into the
police system so when an officer is
responding to that call
and they have to get there before you
know the mental health responders get
there
uh they're able to use that to
de-escalate the scenarios that they see
fit i mean it's this has been going on
for years so
progress in that front requires
obviously more momentum which is which
is a good outcome of the last several
months but also requires more funding
not just on the technology side but
obviously on the human resource side
uh i think you know more practically
speaking you can have this all operate
out of the fire department
the concept of of creating a tertiary
agency that is not police or fire and
just does this
it could work it's just going to take a
lot longer it's going to be more
expensive
in the meantime if your concern is that
you don't want to lump these folks in
with the police department themselves
and you want to make them trained as
fire department employees
because health is mental health and you
i think that makes perfect sense
that's a stop gap it's faster so taking
that approach
number one i think is going to solve for
a large variety of the issues
the rest of it comes down to uh
legislation policies and training
most of which again are going to require
additional funding
i think i'm all for personally
increasing the amount of training
officers have to go through in the
beginning
and increasing continuous training
requirements right now the states have
totally different they have the ability
to have totally different requirements
and what the state of california does
might be you know far
far along the training spectrum and m
you know
much more in depth many more hours than
maybe a different state in the united
states so
that it you know that causes some
discrepancies but funding is usually the
issue for all of those things
and with funding you can also go out and
find better cops because i think
when i say better cops i mean higher
quality candidates to actually apply for
the jobs
i'm not saying that the cops out there
today aren't doing the best with what
they've got
but you know i constantly hear people
say well doctors you know
have to go through all those training or
lawyers have to go through all this
training and
you know what you know if you if you
want to become a cop today
you got to be kind of crazy to do it
that's just the way it feels
because it's not just that the salary is
low but
it's the most hated profession
potentially right in the united states
so you know immediately people are going
to hate you just for
for the fact that that's your job it's
extremely dangerous
and one of the things that i think is so
important in policing and from police
officers is to have empathy
i think empathy and i don't just mean
that emotionally you know in the in the
context of everyday use
for that word i mean empathy also
teaches you how to be a good swat cop
how to know
where you think the bad guy's gonna pop
out and teach you how to be a good
detective where do you think you need to
look for clues
but in the context of what i'm
describing empathy can make you
a better cop it can help you de-escalate
scenarios it can help you
use discretion in a way that end you
know essentially
ends up being the best needs of the
community now the problem is
that people who are you know have that
high level of emotional intelligence
they're very empathetic
they're naturally built to absorb the
emotions of others
and this job policing takes that out of
you
you're constantly dealing with tragedy
every day you're dealing with angry
people you're dealing with sad people
victims you're dealing with people who
hate you you're fighting it's
an incredibly emotionally draining job
on a day-to-day basis
and if you're empathetic not only is
that parking hurt the part that's gonna
hurt is like the fact that
your family and friends might turn
against you you know if the
some type of news thing comes up and
like that's brutal to them too
and and the lack of any type of support
or
just the idea that the country hates you
is going to drain it out of you so what
we have here
all the empathetic cops they they just
they leave they go
okay i can't do this job anymore we're
dealing with a massive amount of
attrition
and we're losing a lot of the cops that
are have that you know
they're empathetic but also have other
options they don't have to be cops
they can they've got degrees they can go
do something else maybe they want to go
back to
you know they want to go to law school
they want to go get into sales they want
to dive into bitcoin bro they can do
whatever it is they want to do
they have options the ones that stay
either love the job like i do i don't
get paid a tremendous amount of money
for this
or they just might not have options and
that is
not exactly progress that's we're going
backwards
does it play into you know look haven't
been in the military lots and lots of
guys end up going to being
prison guards police officers um and
kind of all sorts of
i was called kind of law enforcement or
defense related uh industries and
occupations how much of the training
that we gave
to our soldiers over the last 20 years
as we've been at war in the middle east
uh trickles back into not only the
mindset
but also the skill set and kind of
posturing of
those who end up in law enforcement
positions but then also
it seems like there's a lot of equipment
you know i saw uh
last year at one point the one that just
kind of was like wait a second this
looks like something that i had seen in
iraq
uh was i think was in minnesota uh
potentially there was a video and they
basically had like an mrap right
yeah yeah a mine resistant armored
vehicle going down the uh street of a uh
of a neighborhood
and everyone was decked out and kind of
riot swat gear
uh and they were shooting um you know
smoke grenades basically at
uh at people who were on their porch and
i don't know all the details and so you
know
let's just give the police officers the
benefit of the doubt that
there was more to the story than what we
saw in the video let's also give the
benefit of the doubt to the people
on the porch and say like hey they
probably were pretty shocked that they
got smoke grenade shot at them right so
kind of
everyone ends up in a situation that
they didn't expect but the the scene of
these uh mine resistant armored vehicles
rolling down the
neighborhood streets of the united
states i think just kind of blew
people's minds and so
how do you see kind of the wars and the
military training and the equipment and
all that stuff
uh kind of bleeding into the police
force and do you think that has any
impact on any of this
yeah i mean it certainly does uh but you
know what we have to break it down for a
second because
the concept of you know the
militarization of police you break it
down from equipment you know what they
what they have available to them
to you know tactics and training and how
they're able to handle things and then
policy
and how they use the equipment and and
the training itself so
when it comes to equipment you basically
have to you want to have
what you need to do the job in your
worst case scenario
if something were to happen within the
united states whether it's a terrorist
attack
or you know whatever else is happening
domestically the military isn't showing
up rapidly deploying within 15 minutes
to come to us with tanks and
wraps and all the stuff they need to
handle that unfortunately that's
that stays within the that's going to be
a local law enforcement issue
something happens in this in the city of
la lapd is going to have to respond
the the residents of the city of la for
example are going to need to know that
if someone puts a bomb on the street
that someone like cops are gonna be able
to show up in a couple minutes and start
handling that
and police cars are not bulletproof
the the crown victorias that we use the
ford explorers they're not bulletproof
we don't have that kind of money and
bulletproof vehicles are just they're
they're cumbersome they're not fast
enough
you know this right like they're it's
just it's a gas mileage
they sound so cool so the equipment you
know the
the united states had a program with um
with the u.s military during the
drawdown that allowed them i'm sorry
the law enforcements that allowed them
to either get some of this equipment for
free or at a massive discount
so they could adequately prepare
themselves for some of these worst case
scenarios
people use the word tanks you and i know
these aren't tanks these aren't m1a
like these aren't abrams tanks rolling
around with massive guns and cannons on
them
all these quote unquote tanks are
armored vehicles that are defensively
geared up they're designed so that if
they have to go into a scenario where
people are shooting at them they're
bulletproof enough to be able to handle
that
active shooter scenarios or if they have
to drive to you know uh
through the purpose of like let's say
eod explosive ordnance disposal
they have to have a vehicle that can
approach a bomb and if that bomb
explodes everybody inside that vehicle
stays alive
which is what the m raps are designed
for in the purple you know mine
resistant
arm ambush protected vehicles that's
what it's designed for
um so the idea of having armored
vehicles
you're probably not going to be able to
convince my mom that
i'm supposed to go into a place where
everyone's shooting or something
exploding
without the idea of an armored vehicle
what ends up i
what ends up i i think it's a threshold
is how they're utilized and
uh like where it goes over the top like
what i think
ends up being kind of dumb but this is
my personal opinion is when
you've got like local law enforcement
agencies and their swat teams are like
in in straight up marpat or
or like you know like multi-cam
camouflage because that's just like
that's a i want to feel cool type moment
and separating the i want to feel cool
to i actually need these tools for my
job i think is an easy win
to solve for some of the optics of these
vehicles and this gear and equipment
traveling around
the other thing i hear constantly about
is cops don't need assault rifles or
anything like that it's again that's
unfortunately in
in today's violent world it's it's not
the case
uh if you want a cop to be able to
engage in and you know
accurately shoot somebody which you
absolutely do you know within a range of
beyond 10
10 meters you're gonna want a rifle in
their hands and not a handgun
um there was a shooting that just
happened for example and i think it was
phoenix
arizona just about a month and a half
two months ago this
footage was released where a guy grabbed
a baby uh he took a baby from his
girlfriend
um and she called out and he started
running into traffic he pulled out a gun
she called on and said please help save
my baby he started shooting at a bunch
of random cars in the intersection
the cops showed up in 60 seconds it's a
patrol officer
the officer takes out his rifle um you
know
positions himself in the like you know
right out of the car
and and is aiming at this guy's head and
waits until the
you know they're trying to de-escalate
hey drop the gun drop the gun but then
the guy points
the gun at the baby's head and the the
officer takes one shot
hits him the head drops him runs up
grabs the baby and you can see this
video it's incredible he goes from
taking a shot grabbing the baby sitting
down and becoming a dad like hey buddy
how you doing
and that's that's like the you know
that's something that you need officers
to be able to do too so
we need them to have the equipment for
the inevitably
you know worst possible outcome training
like i was saying is like
what you're describing when they're
shooting smoke grenades when they're
doing all this stuff
that is a case-by-case basis uh in some
cases
you know like after in hindsight i look
back and go okay that's kind of an
interesting decision they made i don't
know if i would have done the same thing
or i will you know in the scenario
itself you just have to operate with
with what you've got it's hard for me to
arm share quarterback that stuff because
i don't know what's going on
in their heads and all we see is 15
second videos um
what i'll say is if they utilize this
equipment
in a way that is outside of policy or
ends up being
unreasonable in hindsight then those
agencies have they
they're ultimately responsible for doing
that in the first place
that ends up being a policy and training
element one of the things that um
i think uh people really underestimate
is
uh there's policies and then there's the
execution of the policies
right um uh and that works both for good
or bad
right so i'll uh i don't wanna say which
department this was with but
uh i came back from uh from iraq uh i
did a ride along for a couple
things like a week or something uh with
a local police department
and uh i rode with the same guy i think
it was like two or three days in a row
and uh one of the first days he
basically said to me you know hey look
uh
basically we're gonna do super basic
stuff but if there's a bank robbery or
whatever
i'm just gonna pull over the side of the
road you're gonna get out and uh
i'm gonna roll to whatever the call is
if it's you know deemed in any way
you know actually dangerous in terms of
the original call and so i was and
that's kind of an interesting uh
approach why would you do that he's
basically explained that in the past
they hadn't done that and they see you
know they got to ride along you know and
there's a
shootout or whatever and yeah and i
don't think anything ever happened but
just like the policy got revised stuff
like hey maybe we shouldn't be bringing
the right along folks that are unarmed
uh to these dangerous situations and so
um yeah
we're going through it and uh towards
the end of the second day
there's a um a call and he uh it's
basically you know somebody wants
uh somebody to go the police to come by
and check on a home
and so i don't remember all of the
details exactly but uh there's two key
parts to the uh the story that i
remember so when we pull up it's
basically one of these like town home
type situations it's an end
unit uh and he's like you know stay here
uh he gets out he's got his
uh his pistol in his hand he walks up to
the front door knocks the door nobody
comes walks around checks the windows
doesn't see anything goes to the back
door realizes that the uh the back door
actually
is uh open and so uh if remember
correctly it was like a check on the
home because maybe it was somebody at
work who like their alarm had gone off
or something
right okay so the back the back door's
open so hey you know put two and two
together maybe somebody broke in the
home
so he basically walks back around the
house comes to me and he says uh you use
the radio he calls and says you know hey
i'm gonna
go check this out and he looks at me
dead and screen the guy and he goes you
know how to use one of these and he
points to the shotgun
that's uh kind of in the uh in the rack
right behind him and i said uh well i've
used one before
and he says great if i'm not back in
five minutes press that red button it'll
release and make sure that you come get
me
and i'm looking at and i'm looking at
this guy and i'm like i definitely know
that's not part of the policy because we
just talked about how you could drop me
off
the side of the road right yeah like
whatever but it
what stuck out to me in that story was
this was a human right and he basically
was like look you know i gotta go do my
job here but there's nobody here no
backup no whatever so
fast forward basically he goes in the
home and uh and within you know 30
seconds 45 seconds whatever
uh there a bunch of cops pull up and
kind of the backup shows up
and uh so i get out of the car what will
the cops all say all they know is that
there's been a call that somebody broke
into a home and they see a guy with no
uniform on it
immediately the cops said who are you uh
well hold on you know i just came in the
car and so what you start to realize is
uh every single part of the iteration of
a story like that
happens every single day over and over
and over again and
there's complexity when there's like a
ride-along there's not an officer or
whatever but you can very quickly see
everyone who's kind of armchair
quarterbacking some of this stuff like
what would you do in this situation
right and do you go in the home do you
not go in the home do you wait for
backup do you not wake up for backup
like do you go in with your gun drawn do
you go in with your gun holster do you
use your flashlight do you not
you know all these different components
and it's just it's an impossible
situation i think uh to get right every
single time
um but but i also think that there's
things that we can do from a technology
standpoint so
tell us a little bit about uh spider and
kind of what you guys are building and
kind of what the impact of
uh this technology and other technology
that uh kind of police officers are
using what that can do for policing
um and really just for them fulfilling
their job to protect and serve citizens
yeah so look spider tech is
the whole goal here is to try and help
law enforcement agencies become
customer service oriented organizations
i mean that's like the big
the big thing we're trying to do the way
that we've kind of approached this i
mean there's a few things that we
fundamentally believe
number one if you were to ask a police
chief 10 years ago
hey what is that key performance metric
that you know will prevent you from
getting fired as long as it goes well
they would have told you oh it's crime
rates crime rate's going up crime rate's
going down that's how i'm usually
measured
uh if you were to ask them today they're
going to tell you that that performance
metric is public perception
crime rates can inform public perception
but ultimately it's the way that the
public perceives
how you and your agency are doing that
is the most important thing which is
reasonable to me i understand that
now the other thing is when i was hired
as a police officer my chief had told me
listen
what we have here is a bank of good will
or bank of trust with the community
every time one of our employees or
officers goes out there
and has a positive interaction with a
community member they're making a
deposit into that bank account
and we need as many people to make as
many deposits as possible because
ultimately someone's going to [ __ ]
something up just statistically
and we have to hope we have enough in
that bank account to catch that check
that's what we're trying to protect
against now i kind of combined those two
things and
at the company we sat then we thought
about it we thought okay listen
we believe fundamentally that
interactions between employees of the
police department
and the community members are
essentially ground zero for all
improvements and declines in public
perception
everything after that is a game of
telephone you can't really control for
it what the media is going to say what
social media is going to say
what you want to focus on is optimizing
and understanding those interactions
that your employees your officers are
having with community members
finding those areas for improvement and
focusing on improving that specifically
and by doing that you will
ultimately increase or improve the
public perception
of your agency but even to do that you
have to start measuring it so that's
part of what we do
now our approach to how to solve this
problem we kind of looked at how
the e-commerce companies were able to
build trust for people to actually put
credit card information
on the internet i mean you and i are old
enough to remember when that first came
out like people didn't just
jump into the internet and go yeah take
whatever you want one of the things they
had to start doing is
like companies like amazon they would
have to start you know when you
bought something they'd have to send you
an email that said hey here's your order
confirmation
your here's your confirmation number and
just by doing that that immediately
made people feel like okay that makes
sense i trust this now that something's
happening
but they're also setting expectations if
amazon tells you your item is likely to
be
delivered on wednesday you're probably
not going to call on tuesday to ask
where your item is
but if they don't tell you anything
you're more likely to call on tuesday
all of this isn't just destroying the
trust between you as a customer and
amazon
it's ultimately costing amazon it would
cost them a tremendous amount of money
if they had to pick up the phone every
single time someone was calling about
their items
they didn't automate this entire
customer service process now similarly
these e-commerce companies are also
sending out surveys
how do you feel about this product how
do you feel about this service and
they're doing that to identify where the
areas for improvement are the
liabilities
they're also doing that to positively
promote good performers in that sense
right
and so we took this type of automated
customer
service platform and we applied it
starting with policing
and the way it works is if you are a uh
you know a
if you live in one of our 50-plus cities
across the united states and canada
you call 9-1-1 the moment you hang up
you'll get a text message says
hey here's your now one call number
here's what to expect you'll get updates
hey you know
when the officers on their way over
there regarding if there's a delay or
something like that
you'll have the opportunity if you want
to actually just cancel a call and fill
out a report you know report right there
on your phone so you don't have to
inconvenience yourself if you want
uh and then when an officer comes and
takes the report and they leave um
you know they they'll submit something
into their system
uh that essentially allows for you to
now get an email or text saying
hey here's your your your case number
here's what to expect here's how a
detective will be assigned here's what
you said insurance company
here's your victim advocate you know
whoever it is that that you need and
then throughout the process
you know a detective's been assigned a
case has been closed an arrest has been
made
and now we're starting to work with
district attorneys to do the same thing
for the court systems as well
to be able to provide that amazon style
customer service now during this whole
process
we're sending out these mobile-friendly
surveys to measure the interactions
hey how did the officer treat you when
they spoke with you how was it your
experience with a dispatcher how's your
experience with the detective
and they're doing that not just again to
identify you know where areas for
improvement are but i think this is the
most important piece
they're doing that to change officer
culture what i mean by that
is positive reinforcement goes a long
way
some of it's carrot some of it's stick
in order to improve officer culture
you have to show you have to help reward
the modern officer for being a modern
officer
right now in from a data standpoint all
these agencies are collecting
enforcement data
i can tell you in most agencies how many
citations someone wrote how many arrests
they made
how many stops they made traffic stops
etc etc
that's gonna be the only performance
data i might be able to gather about
this officer
once you throw in something like an nps
score or
uh you know something along the lines of
how many positive survey responses
they've gotten
and you start rewarding them and patting
them on the back for that metric
they can start pulling away from trying
to show you that they're a good cop
by making stops and writing sites and
and proactive enforcement action
and they can start focusing on just
being a good person when they're
interacting with people
because they can get rewarded for that
and that's what we're seeing within the
you know dozens of agencies that we're
live in
that we've transformed the cultures
there we've almost gamified going out
there and just
providing good community policing and
that helps change the culture
yeah and it feels like what you're
really doing is you're taking the best
of
uh the non-law enforcement world right
the technology world
and you're basically saying let's
incorporate this let's actually use the
uh the feedback let's use the
information the data to get better
what do you see as the biggest changes
that people actually make inside of
these police departments or
these organizations once you give them
that data
yeah that's a great question um look i
mean they're they utilize the data in a
variety of ways
you have the day-to-day operational use
cases where if
you know a good survey response comes in
i'm going to forward it directly to the
officer and give him an atta boy at a
girl
if it's a um you know a negative server
fonts i'm an investigative that's the
day-to-day ability to constantly every
day optimize your organization and not
let anything slip through cracks
we told chiefs that's the i was blind
and now i can see moment that we give
them
but the other side of this is how
they're able to use the data in larger
sets
whether it's you know in monthly
meetings or yearly or
when they go to city council and they
try to allocate funding i'll give you an
example here
um what we ended up having with one of
our our customers
they were talking about a growing
homelessness issue in in
in their city and uh the city council
was saying that this is mostly anecdotal
and
they couldn't really you know quantify
it typically in city council you've got
like
in these meetings you have like a couple
dozen of your loudest
residents will come in and they're
either activists or or they're not
activists they're just residents and
they're your frequent flyers in these
community meetings and those are the
ones that typically you know bend the
ear of the city council people the most
which is
fine that's how democracy works but what
we're doing is now empowering everybody
else to be able to participate in that
conversation to a certain extent
so when this this particular chief who
is trying to explain to council look we
we have an issue with enforcement
uh you know thefts are going up
vandalism's going up all these things
are going up
with increasing homelessness population
and they're saying sorry but we don't
see it
one day he shows up with this large data
set saying
here's you know thousands of survey
responses
from your city council uh a district
city councilwoman from your district
city councilman and going through this
whole process
and then weeks later walking away with a
six-figure
you know addition to the budget so he
has the resources to be able to tackle
that particular issue
including with with uh special mental
health responders
and and homeless liaison specifically to
be able to solve for that so
using this data to basically give
these these cities an understanding of
what's actually happening
so it's no longer anecdotal not just
based on where the crime is but how
people are feeling
because neighborhoods some neighborhoods
might feel like they're underpoliced and
some neighborhoods might feel like
they're overplaced you can't
put a one-size-fits-all there but if
you're asking these neighborhoods
what do you think the problems are what
do you want from us you can actually
start making actionable decisions
and allocating resources appropriately
so that's just one of the examples
yeah i think that's a great example uh
before we get to the rapid fire
questions to uh to wrap up
uh you guys ask me one question uh to
end it where can we send people if they
want to learn more about spider if they
want to find you on the internet
yeah so find me you can find me on
twitter i'm trying to i'm trying to blow
up like pomp here on twitter so i'm just
out there making content dude
uh you can find me just
bitcoin i got to start like talking
about clubhouse i got to move to miami
i gotta do all that stuff and i'll have
a hundred thousand followers by thursday
um yeah i know look it's my twitter
handle rahul but it's
spelled creatively
r-a-h-o-o-l-n-s-i-d-o-o
or whole sudo and uh find us spyder tech
you know follow spyder tech
s-p-i-d-r no e because we're cool tech
people tech t-e-c-h
spidertech.com uh happy to connect with
anybody
and uh talk more about this i'm super
passionate about it spider tech so no e
in the spider but a he in the tech you
gotta you know if you're a
real tech company you would just remove
all the e's yeah you know what we're not
that crazy dude because if you just look
at it it just sounds like gibberish
can't get away with it this is the
spider was acronym when we started it
was a research project for me
you know how police and military love
their acronyms so
it was specialized police intelligence
and data resource
and the idea was how do it was a project
how do we help leverage data to do more
than just catch bad guys
and then learn this lesson if you're a
founder and you're trying to start a
company
and you're thinking really early on
maybe it's time to rebrand pull the
trigger
because when you're several years in
it's more expensive more difficult to
rebrand
don't do it to yourself i could not
agree more uh i got three questions for
you then you get one for me
uh first one what is the most important
book you've ever read
most important book i've ever read oh
good question i'm looking at my bookcase
you know what it's hard it's hard to say
most important what i'm not gonna pull
it up
but uh one book that i just read
recently that i think everyone should
read
because it really uh kind of adds a new
perspective to
humanity is sapience have you read that
one
sapience is good it can be a little bit
of a dry read but i would power through
it because it kind of
explains the history of of you know
humankind in a way that allows you to
adapt that perspective
for a lot of things that we're dealing
with today i appreciate that one that
was one of the more recent ones but
the rest of these books man i got
hacking darwin up here
our final invention live 3.0 just ai
type stuff and the rest of it's on
investing because i'm trying to get like
you dude so i just read your letter and
i read books
i love it uh second one is more personal
sleep schedule i used to sleep five or
six hours now i'm like eight or nine
and uh this one comes from our friends
already sleep they've got a
thermo-regulated bed
super hot super cold i sleep on an ice
cube basically and sleep like a little
baby
uh my wife tells me that i'm a much more
enjoyable person now that i sleep eight
or nine hours and uh
get good sleep what's your sleep
schedule and how's that changed over the
years
yeah man that's a great question um and
i've heard so much about age sleep
and and and so many good things about i
really should give it a try
i will say number one uh whether you
think in eight sleep or something else
invest in your bed like i'm a big
proponent of you sleep you know one
third of your life
or maybe a little less if you know
depending on how you sleep is in bed
spend money on getting something that
fits for you people really really
underestimate that
and with with the you know the creation
of eight sleep and you know like this
kind of smart sleeping concept
really optimizing is important for me
it's important you know i try to get at
least six
hours uh seven and a half is a good full
night's rest for me personally it's
that's an equal amount of sleep cycles
i try to hack it up a little bit i mean
i don't take naps as much as i used to i
try to avoid taking apps and just try to
you know focus all of my sleep uh when i
can
and i'll i'll sleep in on the weekends
at least i'll try and sleep in once and
sleep in for me is a little over eight
hours you know and but then a little
when i get a little bit beyond that i
start feeling bad about myself dude
you know like the guy that wanted to
come on come on yeah
dude no just because i just you can i
don't want to go in like 10 hours i feel
like i could have spent that two hours
doing something else but i will say the
minimum is an absolute requirement and
i've heard guys like elon
you know like all these people that
you'd expect don't have the time to
sleep they're prioritizing their sleep
so why can't we uh yeah i couldn't agree
more you got to get a sleep man i'm
telling you i am a kind i know
dude i know i just tell one of my
friends about it too she needs to go
grab one
third question aliens are you a believer
or non-believer
wow good question yeah i've heard you
asked this question before um
look i am a believer in
the mathematical problem that is
aliens probably exist that's that's as
far
as i'm willing to go um and
i like my mind is open i try to like
kind of
react in terms of probabilities and the
the fact that the universe is so
vast and we know so very little about it
it comes off it would come off to me as
really arrogant to say that they don't
someone
say that aliens probably don't exist
like it's the likelihood is much higher
than they do
the form of those aliens i would say is
like up for debate
um there's a lot to be said about
civilizations that have been extinct
uh or civilizations that are much
earlier than us is bacteria on mars
alien life is you know or are we really
talking about like
half cyborg human beings that are so
like
multiple sons away i mean i could see
both of them happening i don't think
we're going to see him in our lifetime
and i'm not as like caught up in the ufo
side of it
it's all fair what question you got for
me to uh to finish up
well dude um let's see let's see
your favorite seed investment
in the last 365 days i don't know if you
went into aids sleep so i'm gonna take
that off because you already put them in
there
what is your favorite one favorite
seating
i can't pick a favorite okay you know
what no let me let me rephrase let me
let me cut you off
what is a seed investment that you
regret the most
in the last two years that you didn't
make
oh that i didn't make yeah you did um
i'll do one even uh better than that
it's not a seed investment it's actually
an lp
investment so i'm a very very small uh
investor in a friend of mine's fund
uh i don't want to say who it is uh but
he'll know if he hears this
and um he was thinking about starting a
fond
and he's very very well connected very
well known in the kind of tech world
and i was like you should absolutely do
this like no brainer
i'll be the first person to say yes to
you uh we were at dinner
with uh with his girlfriend at the time
and uh and
my wife and we were like yes we're in
like we absolutely will invest in you
you should definitely go do this like we
believe in you
and so that pushed him and he ended up
starting the fund and then
um he kind of went and gathered a bunch
of checks and
uh when it came time for us to invest it
was basically at the end
and uh we were like ah you know we'll
throw a check in we throw
a pretty small check into this thing and
then he went out and he
had an epic fund i mean he literally put
money into
uh one company that ended up going from
nothing to two billion dollars in like
18 months he was in the seed series a
you know like multiples returned
probably one of the best performing
funds of that uh vintage
uh and he just did company after company
after company
and my regret is not that i invested my
regret is that
i believed in my friend so much to
convince him to go do this i believe it
so much that i told him slight unseen of
a deck a strategy anything like i'm in
and then when he was like all right put
your check in like it was more of like
oh i'm supporting my friend it wasn't me
looking at it from like
oh i should really invest a lot of money
in this and so
it's just a reminder that like when you
believe in something then like really
believe in it right it's like
anything worth doing is worth overdoing
i think that we lose sight of that and
investing a lot and so that's probably
like the biggest regret that i have
that's actually that's a really good
answer i i've you know spent so much
time kind of
working with companies and thinking
about investing from a founder
standpoint
that um you know now i'm like kind of at
a stage where i'm
looking thinking like hey if i wrote an
lp check potentially even if it's a
really small one for me
who you know where would i put the money
and i've been meeting so many
like amazingly talented investors who
are previously founders with multiple
exits
i'm gonna plug him real quick matt
berzina is one of those guys
that i've been spending some time with
in the last uh last couple months
and you know just talking to him about
investing um other guys like alex
rubelkava and sean amarati and
like these folks have have really opened
my eyes to what it takes to be a good
investor
i've spent so much time thinking about
what it takes to be a good founder and
ceo and where i would put money there
then i'm learning about that and like to
making that jump i'm sure is
is just as nerve-wracking as it is
elsewhere and going like this is a
business opportunity versus a friend
i mean that's that's scary just believe
if you believe
believe yeah go all in
all right listen thank you so much for
doing this i i really really enjoyed
this i think that uh you sit in a very
interesting spot both in the technology
world and i've seen the law enforcement
side so thanks so much for
taking the time out of your day to uh
share all your insights with us and we
definitely want to do this again in the
future
you got it pop i'll see you in miami